what are you up to no good
despina forces with us how could we
possibly lose
I'm just not afraid anymore you always
have to be the hero while you're playing
a good little boy I'll be busy winning
hey youtubers is Charlie this is my
flash episode 22 trailer video we only
have two more episodes left including
this one as in the end of last week's
episode we got the tease that zoom has
assembled an army from Earth two of all
the metahumans that he's turned they're
going to run rampant on earth one in
central city wall zoom is doing
something else that sounds like zoom
says while you're busy playing the hero
I'm gonna be busy winning so it sounds
like he's creating all this chaos just
letting all these metahumans run rampant
just do whatever you want loot pillage
go crazy while I go off and destroy the
flash there are a couple different
things that zoom can do that has not
been done by the reverse-flash yet he
could go after iris which is why I think
he's doing that or he could actually try
and go back in time to kill Barry but
because we did that during season 1 I
don't think they're gonna completely
recycle that plotline the writers did
say that the emotional things that were
happening in episode 21 between Barry
and iris in particular were going to
build into the final episodes so iris
recognizes she has feelings for Barry
comes clean about them Barry come back
to me so that's why I think that zoom is
gonna try and kill iris they're kind of
doing comic book things but they're
changing a lot just remember during the
Wally West's run how soon went after
Linda Park now wally west was married to
Linda park Barry is married to Iris so a
lot of the people are changed but in the
comics it's you Bart dawn that's always
trying to kill people relative to
Barry's life in Wally West's life that's
zoom so the TV shows just combining a
couple things I mean it's also combining
a lot of the Jay Garrick lore with the
zoom lore so if you have read the comics
take a lot of those storylines with a
grain of salt I just feel like when
Barry is in this room screaming no it
looks like someone's bedroom like he's
in irises room or he's in his home he
could try to kill Henry Allen I know a
lot of us think that the man in the iron
mask is earth to Henry Allen / J Garrick
like John Wesley Shipp the actor playing
Jay Garrick so that it even if Henry
Allen were to die on the show we would
still have John Wesley Shipp playing a
version of Jay Garrick but let me know
in the comments what do you think zoom
is talking about when he says you're
gonna be busy playing the hero cleaning
this giant mess up while I'm busy
winning what do you think that winning
is as if he wants to get rid of all the
people that Barry is close to zoom is
all about not being alone so it sounds
like he wants Barry to have to go
through a version of that like
wants him to feel the pain of being
alone but we have to talk about Katie
Cassidy black siren here effectively
she's metahuman Black Canary but I think
they went with the black siren named
because they wanted her to be an
outright villain fingers crossed she
survives the finale so she can come back
for cameos in the future as a metahuman
but it's the multiverse so all bets are
off when it comes to Katie Cassidy
Laurel Lance it's just it seems like
they have such a sexual thing going on
here like what are you up to no good
like they have some weird sexual history
together maybe she had some crazy
relationship with him before Kaitlyn
came along so either way if she's just
gonna wreck [ __ ] whenever she gets here
it's gonna be a lot of fun watching her
be an evil metahuman but here's my other
question for you guys let me know in the
comments how do you want them to use
Katie Cassidy when she guest stars in
future seasons when she comes for an
episode or an arc do you just want to
see her used in flashbacks on arrow or
do you want to see her be a metahuman
just remember that the flash writers are
committed to doing stuff that is really
weird and really awesome so all bets are
off
really the craziest stuff you could
imagine is probably stuff that they've
been talking about but the really cool
news is is that the writers only took
about two weeks off before they started
breaking season three so they're gonna
be shooting this summer they'll probably
have a trailer for Comic Con so once we
get a chance to see the finale we'll
have an idea for what might be going on
so it's gonna be a lot of fun trying to
guess where they're gonna go because
they said that there's gonna be some
huge twists in the finale zoom will be
dealt with but he's not gonna be gone
for forever just remember how they got
rid of the reverse flash but he's
technically not dead there's almost no
such thing as perma death when it comes
to comic book villains they gave me all
your theories what's gonna happen next
is is tomorrow gonna be a whole bunch of
Game of Thrones stuff so I'll post a
bonus video in the morning then I'll
post my episode 4 video after it airs so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
while you guys wait for my next video
you can click here to get ready for Game
of Thrones tomorrow and you can click
here for my Voltron trailer video it's
from The Legend of Korra people so it
looks amazing thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight